voiture autonome électriques ou encore
intelligence artificielle
voici les sujets d'étude de la voiture
de demain sur lequel blanche des
enseignants-chercheurs de l'estaca mais
le projet le plus ambitieux c'est la
voiture autonome le fait que l'auteur ne
nous cherche donc à l'heure à l'oeuf à
faire fonction de véhicules dans un
situation de conduite urbaine ou péri
urbain sans l'intervention du conducteur
pour assurer un confort et puis
augmenter la sécurité des usagers du de
la route et pour créer la voiture du
futur il y a les enseignants-chercheurs
bien sûr mais aussi les 1800 étudiants
de l'estaca grâce aux associations de
l'université ils peuvent laisser libre
cours à leur imagination comme avec
cette association qui a créé une voiture
de course pour des compétitions
l'association c'est un moyen de
d'appliquer les cours découvre en école
d'ingénieur phase théorique et faire
partie d'une association comme celle ci
permet de pratiquer en fait mais
cependant on apprend de nous mêmes on se
renseigne beaucoup et on est beaucoup en
autonomie le record du monde par exemple
en de tout véhicule électrique ont fondu
et détenus par une forme formula student
donc c'est une seconde 6 au 0 à 100
ce sont des voitures 4 cd est forte
quand une très bonne agilité en virage
une très bonne adhérence et des projets
fous de l'estac à intéresser des
professionnels comme psa renault ou
encore fiat qui n'hésite pas à recruter
des élèves dès la sortie de l'école